we begin tonight with fake news cnn in
nine years as the network's president
jeff zucker
transformed cnn from a boring left of
center news outlet to a still boring
totally completely utterly dishonest
lying anti-trump fox obsessed arm of the
democratic party now zucker's out
bye-bye
anyway in a statement he claims his
resignation is because of a consensual
relationship with another executive that
he did not properly disclose
okay let me be blunt i'm sorry i'm not
buying that for one second now mark my
words the real story will come out one
day and probably sooner than later to me
this statement like so many other things
a fake news cnn it's total
bs or total b
shift adam schiff anyway this statement
like so many other things are fake news
cnn it's just not it's not real zucker's
relationship okay the whole world of
media knew about this for years it was
not a secret people from all across
multiple networks they have been talking
about it for years and remember mean
girl katie couric wrote all about it in
her book published last year
so when jeff zucker's personal
stenographer humpty the dumpty tweeted
that cnn was stunned
humpty was obviously lying and as a
final act of dear deep obedience as
zucker's stenographer humpty dumpty has
been spewing pro zucker propaganda all
day
now we'll likely know a lot more in the
days ahead but his girlfriend at cnn and
it should again as it pointed out it was
a consensual relationship between them
well she formally served this is where
it gets interesting as the
communications director for that's right
former new york governor andrew cuomo
several years ago now it gets more
interesting andrew's brother former cnn
host chris cuomo is according to
numerous sources i have i have sources
everywhere they are preparing a lawsuit
related to his own dismissal and by the
way preservation notices have already
been sent now it would appear
that the cuomo's know a lot about jeff
zucker and the unethical practices and
the double standards taking place at the
so-called facts first network now my
best guess is jeff zucker i bet he's
completely in the loop as it relates to
chris and andrew cuomo and to what
extent time will tell my prediction is
chris cuomo is going to get his full
contract paid out they said they fired
him for cause and my other bet is he'll
likely get a lot more money before all
of this is said and done
but the problem is look at poor humpty
dumpty he seems very very nervous take a
look the chris cuomo reference cuomo was
fired in december and he is not going
out quietly he was fired and there were
reports that he wasn't going to get paid
the millions of dollars that were going
to be on the remainder of his contract
so as a source said to me earlier today
he was trying to burn the place down he
was going to court trying to burn the
place down and claiming that he had
incriminating information about zucker
and gullist so if that's the case if
this is a domino effect that begins with
andrew cuomo going down the governor's
office and then chris cuomo being fired
from cnn and then jeff zucker losing his
job at cnn that is a remarkable domino
effect a chain of events
it's official jeff zucker's stenographer
that guy humpty dumpty is now in a boat
without a runner what's humpty gonna do
uh humpty guess what kissing jeff
zucker's ass like you've been doing for
years it's not gonna advance your
pathetic failing career anymore now his
very generous meal ticket is now gone
and now humpty dumpty may be close
behind look at this from the daily mail
insiders are calling for humpty that's
brian stelter to be fired after failing
to report zucker's quote open secret
affair remember stelter is a so-called
chief media correspondent for fake news
cnn and
let you know he never seems to notice
when his dear leader or anyone on his
network is doing something wrong in fact
one source actually just referred to as
jeff zucker's water boy if you read the
piece you call yourself a journalist
right humpty pretty pathetic now of
course we wish humpty dumpty well we
don't call for firings but i'd be
prepared for one now journalists of fake
news cnn msdnc
every other left-wing network
we don't call for these people to be
fired we don't call for censorship i
never have i'm never going to we don't
call for boycotts either i've explained
why many times you don't like what cnn
is putting out there on the channel
don't watch it change the channel please
watch us it's that simple in fact most
americans already on their own have
changed the channel because almost
nobody watches fake news cnn i think the
ratings are lower now than nine years
ago when zucker took over
now their few remaining viewers are
probably stuck in an airport if you want
to know the truth that's the great thing
about
freedom and individualism and this is
important because some of you get mad at
me that i don't call for firings and
boycotts and cancellations
you get to make the decision based on
what's right for you you don't need to
control what your neighbor is watching
or what they're eating or what they're
celebrating or what they're wearing you
know when people get mad at me because i
don't support cancer culture
boycotts and firings you know now you
know why and it's a simple answer it's
one word
it's uh mel gibson and braveheart
freedom
freedom to decide what to watch
freedom to listen to what you want to
listen to freedom to eat what you want
maybe too much freedom to eat healthy
freedom to drink freedom to you know you
get to decide on for example the vaccine
take it seriously do your research is my
advice talk to your doctor it could be a
matter of life and death but ultimately
freedom lets you decide that
this brings us now to whoopi goldberg
now she said the holocaust was about
evil and man's inhumanity to men
on that point she was right it's hard
for good people to imagine such horrific
evil six million plus jewish people were
slaughtered murdered by hitler and the
nazis i wrote a whole book deliver us
from evil and
and also it was about an evil plan about
a master race on the latter she was
wrong
i am and always will be if you're a long
time watcher a viewer of this show and
listening to my radio program uh there's
no stronger ally i'm one of the biggest
allies of israel and one of their
biggest supporters in the country
uh whoopi goldberg rightly apologized
now she's facing a widespread backlash
she's got a two-week suspension so
whoopi if you're watching if you hear
about this my unsolicited advice you
don't have to listen to me
whatever you do
don't quit
because i personally believe having
known her she's whoopi's like a peace
love and happiness person live and let
live i know because i met her
but i believe her apology is sincere now
i might be wrong time may prove me wrong
time will tell and i bet a lot of money
that she will never say anything like
this again so why are so many people out
there you know unwilling to give a
second chance why not let the audience
of the view it's not me to why don't you
let them decide they want to watch or
not when you're in the middle of a
firestorm my advice would be you just
got to hold on be strong keep moving and
if you want to leave leave on your terms
and certainly not in two weeks never
bowed down to an angry mob you said
something wrong you apologize now you
have an opportunity hopefully abc will
bring you back in two weeks to get it
right and then get on with your career
welcome to the world by the way that we
at fox and we conservatives on talk
radio live every day that's our world
because tens of millions of dollars are
spent trying to get us fired boycotted
and canceled every single day it's been
33 years of my life living with this and
we have always been consistent about
opposing this
unfortunately many in the media mob
they're only all of a sudden now that
it's impacting them now they're starting
to see the light take a look
i want to know who is so frail over at
abc or who is so frail out there
that they can't understand when somebody
makes a mistake apologizes for the
mistake and takes all the corrective
actions that could be taken for that
mistake and then they're still suspended
for two weeks this is something that is
just going to like start
getting ridiculous i mean if woody
goldberg is cancelled
that would be that would be the i mean
that would be the end of this all this
canceled culture
is getting so out of hand i'm on this
show every night
and i say things that i regret all the
time
and sometimes it comes out of my mouth
and i want and i want to pull it back
right
um and i think as long as we can learn
from that and if the apology is sincere
i think we should allow people to move
on and not so-called cancel them you
know i'd like to believe that they mean
what they're saying but i don't believe
them watch what happens the next time a
conservative is under fire keep in mind
morning joe you know the hosts over
there called for a boycott of the trump
white house and white house aides
remember mika also boycotted soul cycle
equinox because the owner held a
fundraiser for donald trump fake news
cnn don lemon encouraged the biden white
house to stop taking questions from fox
news reporters people like peter ducey
you know joe scarborough blasting
spotify for not doing enough to censor
and silence joe rogan all right which
brings me to joe rogan who i also have a
message for i don't know him personally
joe whatever you do
do not back down
no more apologies you are acting in good
faith you're giving your opinion you
have a show you told your audience what
you did that helped you get over covert
thank god you're alive i'm glad it
worked you interviewed the doctor that
was at the top of his game and helped
create the mrna technology that led the
way to the pfizer and modern vaccines
you were right to interview him and
being inquisitive is a good thing not a
bad thing and thankfully right now the
only artist pulling their music from
spotify to protest rogan are a bunch of
old washed up former hippies oh and mary
trump uh pulling her podcast i'm sure
hurt dozens of listeners are so upset
and and disappointed now sadly those on
the left they don't really believe in
free speech they don't believe in the
bill of rights they want government and
big tech to control what you do what you
say how you think
and in other words they want to force
your compliance don't let them hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else